herzlich willkommen zu rolex trade off
finale diese neuen teilnehmer hinten wir
werden heute um eine rolex takers
spielen und ich bitte euch irgendwo hier
in diesem bereich den schlüssel für
diese box zu finden der sich in einem
goldenen umschlag befindet viel spaß
und werden die leute hier gerade alle
nach dem goldenen ticket suchen möchte
ich mich ganz groß bei time is bedanken
und die das natürlich nicht möglich
gewesen wäre über den ersten link einer
video beschreibung bekommt ihr 10 euro
startguthaben und könnt euch damit einen
kostenlosen anteil einer batman oder
yacht master als welcome es sich bei dem
das könnt ihr anteile von collectibles
also ohren sneakern kunst und super
vielen anderen dingen kaufen checkt den
ersten linken video beschreibung aus um
mich und weitere solche aktionen zu
super
die
warte mal cara hat den richtigen spinnt
first try aus über 300 stunden geöffnet
aber das goldene ticket nicht gesehen
die suche geht weiter
viel spaß du wirst im finale
hier erste finalistin ist gefunden es
geht weiter mit einem etwas ruhigeren
spiel ab liegen
wir in diesem glas sind genau ein
kilogramm zucker wir bitten alle
teilnehmer diese schüssel inklusive
inhalt mit genau 750 km was ich ihnen
davon nicht mehr zeit für die schüssel
alleine die 10 736 und so haben sich die
teilnehmer geschlagen
werde dich bitten inklusive der schale
genau 750 g die schiffsreise verändert
alles
[Musik]
sicher dass sie alle schon 16 irgendwie
künftig haben wir nochmal 50 also 100
gramm
[Musik]
ich glaube zu lassen
anne hat abgewogen fast genau das
doppelte 1,4 kilogramm
6107 913
knapp daneben
jobs gibt es geht
wir uns jetzt
bevor ich euch sage wer von euch
gewonnen hat muss ich euch eine sache
zeigen das ist die schüssel die wie
genau 736 es gibt es zwei leute die das
gecheckt haben das war vor lisa louis
nur lisa hatte 746.000 münchen und louis
hatte 744 und ist damit die extreme
[Applaus]
weiter geht es jetzt im sechsten spiel
im nächsten spiel geht es das allererste
mal ein bisschen um körperliches
geschick denn wir werden gegeneinander
dort spielen nicht ich in einem team
gegen anderes team sondern ich irgend
jeden einzelnen der letzte der stehen
bleibt sieht sofort ins finale ein und
ich habe bock denn völker beim
sportunterricht außerdem war das will
was er wo die leute am kasten wo die
leute am kasten durchgedreht sind
[Musik]
das ganze wird so ablauf ich stehe
allein auf dieser seite und werde die
bälle rüber werfen und probieren alle
kandidaten zu treffen die einzige
möglichkeit sich zu retten ist jemand
den ball fängt den auch wirklich fängt
der kann auch nochmal abprallen und
angefangen werden sicher ist man auch
wenn jemand anders den ball für einen
fängt mit ausreichend ist das die
einzige möglichkeit
wir starten
das habe ich mir schon den ganzen tag
gefreut
[Musik]
nah dran eric warnstreik wir gucken
jetzt barrick kommt mal wieder ein grad
nein kein treffer es geht weiter
sein alter
[Musik]
die letzten 2 die letzten zwei dinge
chance haben in diesem spiel ins finale
daran
wer ist dass sie noch einen wurf auf sie
habe einen wurf habe ich noch frei und
quasi gleichziehen zu können wenn ich
treffe jetzt genauso weiter wenn ich
nicht treffe dann ist anna im finale
ich wollte antäuschen oh mein gott es
ist aus das spiel ist aus herzen
gefunden das finale
spiel nummer 4 wir hatten jetzt zwei
schnelle spiele ein schätzspiel und
jetzt kommt es wieder zu einem setzen
damit alle leute auf nachdem sie sich
gerade voraus gehabt haben die gleichen
chancen dafür habe ich noch jemanden von
timeless organisiert alle leute die hier
sind sind nur hier weil sie die
richtigen hinweise in der time lab
gefunden in diesem prozess mussten sie
verschiedene artikel angucken von denen
man anteile bei teilen des kaufen können
einen dieser artikel haben wir heute
mitgebracht und ich bitte euch gleich
den richtigen preis der gerade auf dem
markt dafür gezahlt wird zu schätzen
heilig den kosten von tennis und ich
habe mitgebracht einen macintosh classic
2 zwar ist der unterschrieben von den
apple gründer steve jobs und steve
wozniak kennen das ganze ding stammt aus
dem jahr 1992 diese mission aber mal
gucken was wert ist der witz ist das
tatsächlich einer der hinweise der
gebraucht war um den kompletten satz zu
finden genau in diesem set versteckt
wurde das bedeutet jeder von euch waren
mit absoluter sicherheit schon genau auf
diesen punkt in der tennis- und jetzt
heißt es richtig dass sie mir genau ich
jetzt einfach mal
16.500 550 es geht um den weg nicht und
das bild ist
wieder im bild nah dran aber hat
nämlich 980500 sondern 98.500 wirklich
ich hoffe inständig wie ihm das ist noch
ins finale schaffte war jetzt erhebt so
ein stück brot stück davon ist leider
kompletten
129000 mit unterschrift genau
temperaturen ist alles dabei alles ist
dabei
6300 euro also tatsächlich habe ich die
app schon ein bisschen länger also das
war ganz zuverlässig das gewinnspiel
lang gemacht habe und da ich sowieso
mich so für schuhe und so interessiert
haben mich mal so allgemein super zahlen
im kopf ich habe auch in diesen mac
angeguckt aber es gibt häufig zahlen in
der app die sehr nah beieinander liegen
ich glaube jetzt einfach auf die zahl
verlassen wenn meine einzige chance
national auffällig zu kommen 98.500
wird schätzen die
63.000 guten entscheidungen getroffen
wir hatten gäste von 6000 bis über
100.000 euro eine person hat tatsächlich
nägel mit köpfen gemacht und spot on den
richtigen preis gesagt und das war nur
mit 98
10 das war meine chance ohne sprache ist
ins finale zu kommen das war es aber
noch nicht es gibt eine allerletzte
chance ins finale das ist das spiel
letztes spiel letzte möglichkeit ins
finale zu kommen bestehen auf dem
riesigen trampolin fällt hier im haus in
köln vielen dank nochmal dass wir hier
drehen konnten es wird darum gehen dass
ihr möglichst schnell über das gesamte
feld läuft und jedes trampolin in diesem
feld einmal berührt wie er das macht ist
völlig egal eure füße zellen als
berührung aber jedes trampolin das muss
alles einmal berührt werden wir stoppen
die zeit wir kontrollieren ob ihr
wirklich alle berührt habe und dann
haben wir den journalisten
viel spaß
[Musik]
hoch gepokert
o
[Musik]
[Applaus]
klopp
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und los
wir müssen kurz in die auswertung gehen
an rechner weil wir glauben dass hier
und da vielleicht ein trampolin
vergessen wurde die checken das einmal
richtig und dann gleich wieder da also
zehn minuten pause starten mit der
auswertung derzeit 47 sekunden kara
39,77 sekunden denn
38,93 sekunden dave 43 63 sekunden
jonathan und 27 15 sekunden für
das problem an der sache ist es gibt
genau eine person die alle trampoline
wirklich probiert diese eine person die
jetzt auf den letzten platz im finale
bekommt mission
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der bruder wirklich so hat incity meter
davor
also leute die hinter mir seht haben am
gewinnspiel teilgenommen waren heute
schon voraus eingeladen von denen sind
aber nur diese hier ins finale
herzlichen glückwunsch wird diese
trading woher runterfallen
spielspaß ist
der einzige tour ist an der ganzen sache
das wird natürlich nicht von einem
autorisierten jumps mitarbeiter
gesteuert sondern von mir viel spaß hier
geht drauf und einer von euch wird
gleich mit der rolex nach hause gehen
[Musik]
finalspiel um die rolex startet in
wow
okay wir machen vielleicht doch noch mal
ein bisschen schneller
direkt ablöste
o
pop und wir gehen direkt mittels mit
drei toten
es geht da nichts
[Musik]
bei uns
ist sagt danke
[Applaus]
letzte auch die letzten drei
so haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mein lieber okay die letzten zwei einer
von euch geht voraussichtlich innerhalb
der nächsten fünf minuten eine rolex die
raus
[Musik]
bevor wir jetzt hier zum wirklichen
finale kommen und ich eine rolex
bereiche möchte ich jedem danken der die
serie zu dem gemacht hat was sie war
jedem danken der am gewinnspiel
teilgenommen hat der hier die
möglichkeit hatte heute drum zu spielen
vielen dank dass ihr wer das ermöglicht
und dir viel spaß
egal
vielen dank fürs zuschauen lassen wieder
gerne vergessen kann als abonnieren und
danke an dir in der das leben gemacht
hat was geworden dank